on est parti vous ouvrez un nouveau
monde donc vous sauvegardez votre monde
et vous ouvrez un nouveau monde parce
que il faut mieux repartir à plat créer
son propre monde un rêve devenu réalité
pour ces douze jeunes guyancourt toit
depuis lundi 29 février ils se
familiarisent avec le logiciel connu le
but programmer leurs jeux vidéo de a à z
les objectifs c'est découvrir la
programmation développer leur imaginaire
et puis après faciliter les échanges
entre jeunes au lieu d'être devant seul
devant leur ordinateur là ils peuvent
échanger modeler un terrain construire
un personnage ou imaginer des
labyrinthes autant de possibilités
facile à réaliser grâce à une interface
ludique
tout est beaucoup plus simplifié au
niveau du mapping et des programmes en
fait du coup c'est vraiment plus
accessible aux bas aux plus jeunes
ça nous apprend à un peu a programmé à
comprendre le jeu vidéo c'est bien parce
que si on fait ce métier plus tard
borman on sera déjà ce coût enfin
comment on pourra faire les apprentis
concepteur de jeux vidéo ont encore la
journée de jeudi pour se former
le logiciel est gratuit ils pourront
donc repartir chez eux avec leur univers
et continuer à laisser libre cours à
leur imagination